welcome back to the realest podcast in
the dunya the three muslims today we got
a very special guest with us but bobby i
got a question for you are you ready for
a news perspective today
absolutely man let's go i'm the little
man let's go so before we go in anything
on your mind that you want to tell us
as we talked about briefly because we
are running short on time here for the
viewers as well uncle only has 20
minutes with us
so i would say we make this a
two-part interview two-part talk and
let's jump right in with veganism at
first before we discuss islam
perfect man so being born muslims right
and i know reverts to their their into
you know we have to eat halal meat as
muslims we don't have too much
experience with veganism i'm sure there
are some muslim vegans i don't
particularly i'm not a scholar or
anything but i i don't think that being
a vegan is anti-islam right i think
having a belief that we're not allowed
to eat meat and we shouldn't eat meat
because of that i think that might get
into haram territory but if someone
wants to be vegan by choice i don't
really particularly think there's
anything wrong with that um because i
don't think it's an obligation to eat
meat
so what's your experience as a
non-muslim being an orthodox christian
with veganism and just meat in general
the same would apply here it's not an
obligation you don't have to eat meat
you don't have to do anything in
particular when it comes down to diet
however in the christian orthodox
background you have a very interesting
fasting practice so it is not like
ramadan where you don't eat at all where
you don't drink at all for many many
hours on end but the christian orthodox
they eat plant-based as a fast so they
are cutting out all the meats they're
cutting out dairy eggs and they're just
eating plants
right
come again
david's fast
yeah similar it's the fest that we do
for eastern and for christmas
and it's quite interesting because
they already understood that if you're
abstaining from the meats
you're essentially abstaining from
nourishment and therefore it is a fast
the vegans on the other hand believe
that
you can get all your proteins from
plants you can get all the nutrition
from plants they don't understand that
they find themselves within a fasting
mimicking state nevertheless that being
said within the bible you have a very
interesting passage that says in the
future
it is revelations in the future there
will be people that will tell you to
abstain from the meats and forbid you to
marry
so it's an interesting revelation and
nowadays i think we find ourselves truly
in a time where people want to forbid
you to get married to be promiscuous and
to go vegan ultimately to drink the soy
so it's quite interesting in that
context
nevertheless yet again as a christian
you could technically go vegan but it's
definitely not something that would be
promoted by the christian orthodox
church
yeah
interesting
yeah veganism that's like
that's a whole conundrum in and of
itself
like
people are just the only way people
really thrive on veganism is if they go
excessive excessive on the plants
and even then they're adding protein
powders and
and some are like
supplementing with eggs so they're not
fully fully vegan
they're uh
vegetarian
how long did you do it for angel how
long did you go vegan
i did veganism for
like a year and a half almost two
it sucked
it sucks man i remember i was i was
doing my training
uh very intense i was eating macros like
on point
but my body was just losing muscle every
single day like by the end of the
veganism
i looked like a almost like a like an
emanciated kid from africa and you know
mega forgive me but it's like
that's almost the degree that it looked
like except with like a really big
stomach
um
absolutely
not sorry absolutely because plants have
fibers that are not digestible for human
beings it is even called insoluble fiber
for a good reason
if you look at herbivores they can
ferment certain plants we on the other
hand cannot meats and fruits come with
enzymes that help you with the digestion
this is when you have a meat meal or a
fruit meal it doesn't bloat you
like when you eat vegetables this is why
all the vegans get the skinny fat look
where they're skinny but they get those
pot bellies
yeah respects like man i remember i was
always bloated i remember i always felt
weird just like
mentally foggy didn't have energy
um
i didn't like it man and throughout the
years i've been you know i had
i came out of vegan diet and went
straight into a carnivore so it was like
one extreme to the other bro yeah
but i realized like you know what
carnivore wasn't really it was a good
elimination day just to see like okay
well my body needs this and he's that
um
but over the years i've been kind of
like leaning more towards what you just
said like meat and fruits
that's the best
it really is bro like for a long time i
kind of
i don't know what's happening with the
other two brothers but
yeah
they don't want to talk about veganism
nah they definitely do it's an
interesting talk it really is man like
anyone who's listening um nutrition is
just interesting in general
but
man like for the for the longest time i
was thinking to myself like maybe maybe
meat and fruit can't really be it
because you know they put this live like
oh you need this amount of fiber you
need to get this fiber from these
different sources and all that but it's
like
man i i don't know i can't speak for
everyone but definitely for myself
meat and fruit has been it maybe like a
few nuts or almond butter or like dark
chocolate in there but that's freaking
like [ __ ]
yeah
i have as i said an almost one year old
child a son thank god and
i let him eat what he wants so i let him
choose
and the things that he chooses hands
down always
fruits
raw fish sashimi
and meat
that's it sashimi fruits meat mangoes
and raw fish you can eat all day a
little bit of chicken a little bit of
beef that's it
he doesn't eat anything else i tried a
little bit of rice he takes a little
nibble and that's that so intuitively
you see that fruits and meats agree
perfectly fine with our digestion it's
amazing
man sashimi but it's something else yeah
it's beautiful absolutely that was my
vegan break that's how i broke veganism
with sashimi and i felt as if my my
light turned back on it was quite
amazing i did veganism for four years
man and i remember finding your channel
angle and i asked you back then in the
comment section are you vegan as well
and you answered yes i remember that to
this very day
because i remember you had a shaved head
and a beard similar to me and i just
started with youtube so i was like oh
that's interesting what kind of content
is angel making and you were talking
about similar things you were talking
about nutrition you were talking about
no fab
psychedelics a bit here and there so it
was quite interesting content that i
could relate to because i was into all
of those things myself
but yeah ultimately veganism i did it
for four years straight for the viewers
that don't know
and during those four years because as i
said in the christian orthodox faith it
is a fast
i felt
after a while that i pushed it so far
that i fasted my body so far not only
physically but mentally spiritually i
was just drained that i lost my
connection to god completely
so therefore i want to repeat it's not
obligatory
that you have to eat meat as a christian
or in your case as muslims but i would
say that if you don't you will lose the
connection to what it means to be human
because god has created the meat for us
as well and if you don't follow the
patterns that are laid out by god then
you will ultimately suffer so it's very
very simple i mean if you jump from a
building
everybody believes in gravity
so you jump from a building and you're
gonna suffer certain repercussions or
maybe you're gonna die maybe you're
gonna get injured that is because there
is such a natural law
and the same natural law
goes a bit further it's not only about
gravity but it's about nutrition it's
about behavior ethics morals etc etc we
can get into that a bit later
but if you don't conduct yourself by
that framework then you will suffer it's
very simple and god will let you do that
too
nobody forces you to eat the meat but
ultimately you're going against your
physiology you've got given physiology
and that's why the vegans suffer
ultimately you will see that they will
get depressed
you mentioned brain fog
absolutely you're not functioning well
anymore many experience anxiety plenty
of famous vegan youtubers they're all
antidepressants nowadays so that is not
a normal state to me you cannot tell me
that that is healthy if your diet is so
healthful if your morals are aligned
with not eating animals
why do you need antidepressants life
should be perfect but they're still
suffering tremendously
many are even i don't want to get into
too much detail but they're bleeding out
of the other end
because of wrecked digestion to that
extent teeth are rotting out
and i had a barrage of similar ailments
until i finally gave in and start eating
the raw fish the eggs etc and this is
curiously enough
when i felt the urge to return back to
god
because i realized wow
all of this science that i've been
presented with the plant-based diet is
suitable for all stages of life it's
helpful for everybody go vegan feed your
kids vegan
didn't work
so i was putting my trust in men
and not in god instead of accepting the
way that it is
and every time you accept life as it is
i know in islam it would be called to
submit
yeah then you come back to peace
and that's the only way of being
every time you think that you know
better than god you're obviously not
submitting but you're rebelling against
god and that can be something that you
do with dietary practices as well
because you don't want to accept the
reality that the animals are here for us
to eat
yeah
damn subhanallah bro we got a comment it
says i'm a secondhand vegan i eat cheap
and cheap eat grass
so bro based on that i guess we're all
just gonna be second hand vegans not not
primary bro
but i got a question for you before uh
you know i pass it back down on because
i was a few minutes left
what are your thoughts on halal
slaughtering have you seen a halal
slaughtering i know we talked a little
bit last night but when you first saw it
what was your experience with it
when i first saw it i just converted or
reverted to christian orthodoxy and
therefore
as i mentioned in my video i had a
strong opposition to islam still but
then i saw that video that video of the
halal slaughter for people that haven't
seen it
the guy in the video for me personally
looked just like jesus he came there
with his long hair and a long beard it
just looked original like you would
imagine jesus to look like and he was
just as peaceful as jesus was described
and he showed how the animals submit
to the slaughter that they just submit
their will they're not rebelling they're
not fighting and it was absolutely
amazing and i said this is the muslim
jesus if i've seen anybody
this must be it it was crazy for me to
see especially coming from the balkan my
uncles my family members they're all
butchers and hunters
so when they slaughter they take a big
hammer
and they ram that hammer to the
forehead of the animal and
knock it out let's say
semi knockout oftentimes it's still
conscious and then they slit the throat
so that was the slaughter that i've seen
and therefore i always thought okay the
western type of slaughter will use a
bolt gun to the head
is the
better version
but then i saw that type of slaughter
that halal slaughter
and i really didn't know
that that was possible to begin with to
be totally honest i'm always skeptical i
would really love to see
not because i'm a sadist or anything but
i would really like to see the whole
slaughter process
because he only shows it until the
moment right and then the screen goes
blank
i know on youtube you cannot really show
those things but i would really like to
see the whole process i would like to
see if the animal is still submitting
when the throat gets slit
yeah that would be interesting to see
huh right yeah it was amazing to see man
i love it
if it would be like that all the time i
think more people would ditch veganism
right away and eat halal meat
for sure
can you guys hear me
yeah yeah yeah all right i have been
lagging like crazy i don't know if you
guys saw so i need to restart
uh one thing i will say is um actually i
heard mufti monk uh a more prominent
muslim speaker he was saying that
when the halal slaughter you know takes
place when he actually you know
slaughtered the animal it does kick and
it does move but this is actually more
of a mercy it's it's good because it's
basically pumping out more blood
yeah it's going to end up you know
getting rid of more blood which we know
that diseases are passed through the
blood of the animals and stuff so it's
actually for the best for us to eat it
but with that being said i'm gonna
restart my my computer and i'll be back
of course yeah do you think no do you
think
it's the halal butcher man it's it's a
beautiful thing
when you see it
um
but i think
honestly the only thing that i wanted to
say prior
to what we were talking about is that
you know you got god made it very simple
for us
god made it very simple for us and
when he created adam and eve like
we are the sons of adam and eve and we
have
we have basically
you have generations and generations and
generations that have come to what we
are now right so we're just a mixture of
all these different generations now
god made it to where
our bodies adapt
like this is this is just a fact i mean
you go to the gym you work out your body
adapts instantly it's like instant
feedback you're seeing it firsthand it
starts adapting getting stronger or
getting bigger whatever the case might
be if you are recovering and you're
eating appropriately right
now adaptations occur all throughout
your life and if you're thinking that
these generations that live beyond you
didn't have these adaptations that
occurred that kept occurring until it
got to you like you must be out of your
mind because like
at some point you have to see like
people
had adapted to
hunting gathering
at some point
another group of people adapted to
farming
and then at some point a group of people
adapted to
that uh shepherd shepherd type lifestyle
which is kind of a mixture of
hunter-gatherer and the farmer in a way
because they're farming animals so they
have
that consistent food but they're really
fasting a lot and they're kind of eating
whatever they find
yeah with that being said with that
being said man like
um someone even mentioned here that some
people just need more protein and this
is true like the people who
have you know the adaptations from the
hunter gatherers we tend to do better
with
me and fruit
and maybe a little bit of extra stuff on
the side then you have the people who
they originated or they stemmed from the
farmers they adapted
like this therefore they can eat
a lot of plants they can eat
a lot of carbohydrates a lot of
vegetables they're all right with it you
know their body doesn't seem to give
them any issues
but it's like you have to see the clear
difference and even then even then
these people who their body doesn't give
them any issues with the vegetables or
carbohydrates
they still eat meat
exactly
there's a very interesting book called
nutrition and physical degeneration it
was written roughly 105 years ago by a
guy called western a prize
he was a dentist a vegetarian dentist
who went out on a journey to find a
vegetarian slash vegan population
so he went to africa he went to south
america
he went even to rural areas in europe
because 105 years ago there was still
some more rural areas and you want to
find that vegetarian population as a set
but obviously he couldn't find them what
he did find however is perfect dental
health within those indigenous people
and then he noticed that they were all
eating
meat predominantly and very very little
plants
the point is that
sure
the diets differed a little bit but
ultimately it was always predominantly
animal foods with a little bit of plants
that were either fermented or pickled
like sourdough breads
pickled vegetables etc etc
[Music]
and that is the point that people have
to understand there's never been a vegan
civilization civilizations have been
built on meat our civilization as well
now if you want to go to the supermarket
and get your tofu or your soy drink the
truck driver that brought the tofu into
the supermarket eats meat the cashier
eats meat as well right the workers that
build that supermarket build it on meat
too
everything is founded on that so if you
want to make the claim yeah well we
never did it before but now we can
it would mean you would have to change
your biology and of course this is why i
attack veganism if you will i'm speaking
against it because veganism goes hand in
hand with a transhumanist movement
because the people know intuitively that
humans cannot get away long term with
eating only plants
therefore our biology our flesh is bad
bad bad humans and we have to get away
from our own biology
from the way that god made us but hey
forget about it there is no god anyways
that's what the atheists and the vegans
think so therefore it doesn't matter if
we just change our dna
we can start of course with certain
procedures that i'm not going to mention
here in the current scenario we're not
allowed to talk about those things
anyways here on youtube
so i'm going to keep it as censored as
possible but there are certain
technologies that can change the dna of
the human body and this is where this is
leaded ultimately because
veganism is not meant for human
consumption
you have to change what you are in order
to cope with that deficient diet there
is a very very good reason why people
like bill gates are buying on buying
farmland and other biggest farmland
owners and they're promoting beyond
burgers
you have to think about those things and
put one in one together to understand
what kind of diet they want to feed the
population
we got a comment that says just want to
say bobby all slaughter leads to kicks
and convulsions that doesn't matter the
main thing is when the carotids and
jugular are sliced the animal goes
immediately out
fair enough i didn't know that
i was thinking that you need to
i mean obviously because i grew up
around those practices that you need to
knock it out prior because the lights
don't go off
when you cut the jiggler
but i don't know
i would have to look into it yeah yeah
it's interesting for sure i remember
hearing that um when you do you know cut
the jugular and everything there's some
kind of nerve or something that is also
sliced so
the the neurons aren't transmitted
transmitted so they don't actually feel
the pain after you know us at a certain
point as soon as it's [ __ ] a slit
that's what i remember hearing but you
know allah adam something to be looked
into and may be discussed by
professional as well
might be it might be yeah either way it
doesn't matter ultimately you will not
get around eating meat as a human being
i make that argument just last week it
was or two weeks ago i had an interview
with a 14 year ex-vegan she was vegan
for 14 years
and that was the longest case i ever
heard about and she ended up in the
hospital
bleeding internally and she almost died
so that was the longest case ever 14
years on a plant-based diet she tried it
all be it fruitarianism raw veganism
junk food veganism call it what you will
and in the end she end up in the
hospital
and what more proof do you really need i
mean people get all kinds of diseases by
eating that way and on top of that
people are already eating an 80
plant-based diet
that's something what people don't
understand they're talking about the
standard american diet
what do you think about
burgers
fries
sodas
that's all plant-based
the fries are potatoes that's plants the
soda is sugar comes from the sugar cane
as a plant the burger bread wheat is a
plant lettuce tomatoes onions
plants then you have a little bit of
meat with cheese that's it that's the
only animal food within that whole menu
so ultimately people are already eating
an 80 plant-based diet
therefore you see a push to make it 100
or eat the bugs as they say nowadays as
well there's a push for eating bugs
nowadays
eating the soy eating whatever in order
to replace those nutritionally dense
animal foods and to bring people away
from health but ultimately i see it as
something spiritual as i said because i
saw it on my own body and on my wife as
well
that after veganism we both felt totally
detached from god
completely there was nothing left
anymore
just left alone
and i think that if you don't go towards
god
god won't go towards you either you have
to make a step
[Music]
uh you have the same kind of
consciousness awareness even in humans
is from the reticular activating system
and it's extremely sensitive to ongoing
blood flow if you stop blood flow
abruptly it's guaranteed no
consciousness from that moment on
i don't know i didn't know that
interesting i didn't know that either
yeah brazos are going to say that um
it's the extremes you know the extremes
that
disrupt our
nutrients that we're getting in but like
um proper nutrients i should say so if
you go to veganism at first people feel
more spiritual
why do they feel more spiritual it's
because like you said you're you're
basically uh
almost
you're almost fasted and when you fasted
you feel very spiritual you feel very
close to a god so it makes sense right
but the more you do it the more you are
like depleting yourself of the proper
nutrients that you need therefore
ultimately you're just going to
uh exhaust yourself and then you're not
going to feel the connection to god at
all
same goes with carnival bro like with
carnivore you are missing
certain nutrients you know like you're
in keto you know it's good
it's a healing type of way
but you're not supposed to do keto all
the time and when you're in keto for a
long period of time like
the body is not really producing insulin
the way it should therefore it's not
holding on to water and electrolytes the
way that it should therefore you have to
supplement with
outrageous amounts of electrolytes
and think about it like where do the
electrolytes come from
comes from the fruit
and then maybe some plants in there if
you really want to include the plants
that is absolutely correct man i say
that every time you need to supplement
anything you already know that your diet
is deficient i mean it's quite obvious
otherwise why would you have to
supplement
on the vegan diet you need at least b12
you could make the argument for vitamin
a as well vitamin b6 d3 k2 creatine
carnosine there are many things that you
might want to supplement as well but
nevertheless on a carnivore diet long
term the same applies and you see as
well when they do blood tests that
long-term carnivore leads to decreased
thyroid function and decreased
testosterone levels as well
so it is just not sustainable i think in
the diet community people want to
reinvent the wheel and it's alluring
that you found the holy grail so to
speak it's just eating meat just eating
plants
but ultimately we all know that we've
been eating both for the longest time so
it's actually not that complicated the
best thing to do is simply to stay away
from the processed stuff and eat as
close to nature as possible that's not
rocket science ultimately um
you wanna do you have to get going soon
uh let me check the other see if he's
here
so we got a question here uh asks bobby
what his opinion on dates are
dates food or dates dating dates i'm
assuming since ramadan bro dates
man i love dates back in the day when i
used to still hardcore bodybuild in my
early 20s i used dates as my
post-workout shake replacement so dates
bring you very quick sugars there's a
lot of glucose within dates so therefore
i know that you guys use it to break
your fast it's perfect for that because
it brings the blood sugar back up i
always use that post-workout in the
beginning i use supplements like
maltodextrin or dextrose or any type of
simple sugar but then in the end i said
why would i just drink my calories if i
can sit down and enjoy some beautiful
medjool dates so i did rather than
instead and yeah i love dates it's
absolutely delicious man perfect man
bobby wins the beard battle between
y'all bobby give us some beard advice
your beard looks good marshall yeah i
agree bro what's your routine bro thank
you very much bro i have to disappoint
you guys you have to choose parents for
that i don't do anything with my beard
it's just hairy balkan beard
i trim it here and there uh guys my bad
pause for one second um
i do gotta get going the brother is here
we're about to head out
um it's been honestly growing it's been
great
um
yeah god willing we'll all be able to
get here together and target absolutely
what was cool that you stopped by bro
yeah i'm glad i did no
yeah man i look forward to looking i
yeah i look forward to looking at the
rest of the stream later on inshaallah
all right then bro take care of him
[Music]
oh i was about to end the broadcast
[Laughter]
there is no routine guys honestly i
don't use any products on my body other
than simple soap
that's it i just use soap so when i was
backpacking through thailand i picked up
that habit and i was just using the
little hotel soap and i liked it so much
that i just stuck with it because it
gives you a very nice dry feeling after
the shower
and that's it i don't use any beard oils
back in the day i even had a bigger
beard and i was thinking about
advertising for a beard oil because
companies started writing me on
instagram
and i said yeah well
i'm not using it so i'm not going to lie
about it i don't use anything i tried a
little bit of moroccan oil
i forgot the name of it for a while i
think it made it a bit more luscious but
not the type of guy that sits around and
does that
you talking about organo yeah that's the
one no argan oil yeah
i
can't find the time for that man
i don't have it i'm just too lazy to do
that i just watched
that
i asked angel a few times like what is
what is your beard routine he's like bro
barely anything
you know there's some different types of
oils that he uses you know some stuff
that we're gonna discuss in a few videos
insha'allah for the viewers but uh
anyone that made it this far smash that
like button check the description
there's probably already time stamps
right by the time they see it after the
live stream um so you guys can like pick
and choose and a lot of people are
probably gonna skip to this part where
things are gonna get real bro but i got
a question for you
being an orthodox christian for people
that haven't seen your video
what's your journey with the quran
because this is something you've been on
the team show i think a day or two ago
alhamdulillah i saw a little bit of that
so i'll snip it of that but for people
that haven't caught up to speed on that
and give us a little bit about your
story
yeah my story is that
first i have to say the quran out of my
context is the forbidden book
so we don't read it right it's the
devil's book we don't touch it simple
i grew up as a christian orthodox but i
have to say that my parents were kind as
secular
they both believed in god but we would
go to church only for christmas and for
eastern
that's about it and for weddings of
course but other than that we wouldn't
go every sunday like most christians do
but culturally
i am from macedonia that is a small
country on the balcon
we have a very very long history with
islam and
battling islam because for 500 years
there was the ottoman occupation
on the balkans
and the ottoman empire spread
up to austria even so it encompassed
serbia croatia macedonia bulgaria all of
that became
muslim if you will it was the caliphate
and in the end after the ottomans were
defeated
only the bosnians and the albanians
if i'm not mistaken i think those are
the only two groups that stayed muslim
on the balkans
and we were proud of that right so that
is something that is celebrated to this
very day
there's my baby in the background
screaming if you hear it hey
yeah anyways we are very proud of that
as a nation we defeated the turks and
for the longest time i believed that
it's going to be funny for muslims i
thought that islam is a turkish faith
i had no idea that it's arabic
at all i thought the turks invented it
and we even have a saying on the balkans
that we will never take on the turkish
faith
that's it
if you look at muslims on the balkan
even if they're ethnically slavic
they're considered turkish
so that is the context on the balkan
everybody that is muslim is
automatically a turk
macedonians that became muslim during
the ottoman time are considered turks as
well
and it's quite interesting that those
groups on the balkans they don't mingle
so we don't talk to the albanians they
do their business we do our business
nowadays it's a bit different but
especially throughout the 90s 2000s
it was like that we don't talk with them
we don't mingle with them you don't see
any intermarriage and they're always
considered the enemy 2001 then was the
last war against the albanians and this
is when a lot of atrocities happened
as it is with war
and many albanians started shooting
christian orthodox churches as well
and that cemented it for me of course
i said well that confirms it the muslims
hate us
so i have to hate them there is no other
choice i'm not gonna bow down now and
just accept it they are our enemies
and since then
i built up this hate so to speak against
islam in my heart and that got confirmed
even in germany because
i lived in germany pretty much my whole
life
in germany most muslims that i met were
involved in criminal activity to be drug
dealing gang violence prostitution even
robberies and whatnot i had a few muslim
friends but even those guys would always
report on oh man i have to go to jail
now i have another court meeting my
brother is in jail
oh bro that is hard arm
while smoking a joint
that was always it that's what i would
see they would tell me how hard arm it
is to do those things
but they would still do them
consistently so i thought to myself well
man this just confirms it
i saw islam as violent on the balkan
they started the war and now i just see
a lot of criminality here in germany so
that must be it that faith itself must
be violent must be something that leads
people down that path because i don't
see the christians do that
of course nowadays if you look on the
broad scale you will see christians
committing a lot of atrocities as well
but from my bias perspective that just
confirmed it and therefore i didn't want
to look into it at all even though i
wasn't strongly identified religiously
culturally i was identified as a
christian orthodox always and i saw no
need to look deeper into that religion
then in my 20s i got into partying a lot
and through partying
saw a lot of different angles of life
involving of course drugs as well and
that opened up my perception to buddhist
practices hindu practices because
believe it or not those dance events
techno events they go hand in hand
sometimes with a little bit of hindu
influence you have goa trends and
whatnot
anyways i looked into all the religions
essentially
other than islam all of them i checked
them all out i looked into the hare
krishnas buddhism whatever i looked into
the athletics mayan calendars
and then i got into psychedelics myself
i experienced
magic mushrooms i started growing magic
mushrooms myself and then i decided you
know what
religion is all fake anyways i have to
go to the source
what was pre-religion
shamanism paganism
that's it i have to go to south america
and drink ayuasuka the psychedelic brew
of the shamans with the native people so
i did even that man
i participated in the ceremony
we were brewing the ayahuasca drinking
that going on a vision quest and whatnot
i did it all
but i still didn't look into the quran
after that as i said in my video i was
left with essentially a feeling of a
void i was a vegan
tripping out on mushrooms
seeing all kinds of spiritual things but
still having no connection to god
that i used to have as a child
as a child was simple i would go to bed
pray
and feel that connection with god and
now after all that journeying
i felt further away from god than ever
before so how can that be so much
spiritual work and now i have no
connection to god at all
and that's when i felt this strong pull
to really look into religion again and
naturally of course culturally
essentially the only way for me to look
into religion was of course christian
orthodoxy that was what was presented to
me at that time and at first i
absolutely embraced it and i felt at
home and to this very day i have to say
for people that even reaction videos on
youtube you see muslims reacting to
orthodox church choirs
the choirs are quite beautiful to listen
to it has a very spiritual depth
and that
really made me feel at home made me feel
like oh there's a true spiritual
connection to god here
i went so far to go to mount atos which
is for people that don't know kind of
like the mecca of christian orthodoxy
it is an island in greece
that hasn't been touched for a thousand
years you still have the monasteries
from a thousand years ago and on that
island live only monks only male monks
no females nothing those guys look
isolated they're like in a prison
just to worship god it's quite
interesting i went over there spent some
time in the monastery learned more and
more
but during that search
i realized that i was the first one in
my family to really look deep into our
religion
and this is when i found out about the
trinity
and all the rest the theological
explanation
and for me personally that was quite the
shocker
because i never thought about god in a
triune fashion why would i i don't think
that anybody does to this very day and i
know i'm gonna upset christians and that
is totally fine i upset people all the
time on my channel i really don't care
i'm just gonna tell you what i think
that's why i call my channel as well
bobby's perspective
nevertheless i was very confused hearing
that but i didn't want to go back to my
own ways and i said
i have to accept this religion the way
that it is because otherwise i follow my
own will and not god's will so if god
revealed himself like that to us
i have to submit my will and i have to
take the religion as a whole because
otherwise i'm going to cherry-pick
certain things
and make it fit my own agenda and that
is dangerous
so therefore i took it as a whole i did
the fasting practices the vegan
passing practices
that was terrible because after four
years of veganism to go back to a vegan
fast was quite hard
and ultimately i started
trying
to i like to say brainwash myself into
believing that god is a trinity
so i started trying to make sense out of
it it's not one plus one plus one but
it's one times one times one and
therefore it is still one
and essentially the
father is the origin
but he begets the son eternally through
the holy spirit and i said man
that's really not me here
what am i trying to accomplish
but i stuck with it two years time man
two years time it took me
to
try to convince myself of it but
ultimately i couldn't make myself
believe it and this is when i started
speaking about it slowly but surely on
my channel got a lot of backlash of
course from the christian community
and this is when a lot of muslims came
over to my channel because
they noticed and that's when they said
okay why don't you read the quran and i
said you know what man
after all of that that i've been through
no worries i'm gonna read the enemies
book and so i did
and and what did you find in the enemies
book
yeah it's quite amazing man as i said in
my video
the most impressive
or most shocking thing to me is
that right away from the first passage
it says
it glorifies god
right the most merciful the most
gracious
and that was shocking to me because i
haven't read anything like that within
the bible
which is not a knock on the bible
because i say that the bible is a
different type of book it's much more
like a library of different books and it
doesn't even claim to be the word of god
at all times it's much more of a
library of different works
take it for what you will
but it doesn't start with glorifying god
as such and that was very impressive to
me
i didn't
expect that to be within the quran
moreover
i have to say what was the most shocking
aspect to me which for you guys is
absolutely common sense and you're
probably wondering why i'm gonna say
that
but the oneness of god
and believe it or not
was the most shocking aspect for me
because i thought that islam is a
religion about violence about hijabs
about not eating pork whatever
on that note i'm not eating pork myself
i haven't touched pork since i'm 16
years old i
don't eat any of that and i'm 34 35
almost
yeah anyhow for 20 years i haven't
touched pork that being said yeah i
thought that is the religion and it has
nothing to do with
the oneness of god
during my spiritual
adventures if you will i experience the
wonders of god
with and without those psychedelics
those shamanic brewers the oneness of
god is something that is innate to us
and that we can experience
once i started reading the quran finding
out about the fitra
that was the most powerful thing
because it explained the natural
predisposition of humankind to worship
one creator
and that made all the sense in the world
hands down yeah this is why the quran
was so powerful reading it
and i have certain questions for you
guys but i'm going to keep it for the
end
i just want to say that
that innate predisposition that is
mentioned within the quran is i believe
something that would benefit
christians and any other religion as
well
just to remind them of the oneness of
god and bring at least their mental
focus back onto that
yeah yeah 100 wrong very beautifully
said honestly that is very beautifully
said in islam
the belief of
allah that there's no god worthy of
worship except allah which means a lot
more than you know it sounds like
which we can get into later is the most
important thing we call it
which is establishing the oneness of god
or understanding the oneness of allah
is the most important thing in islam and
you can definitely not be a muslim
without believing in that because to be
liable god as allah says in the quran is
is you know one of the worst things who
is worse than a person who lies about
allah actually there's a very beautiful
there's a few verses in the quran
actually a small surah that we have
prepared for you to listen to a
presentation of insha allah in a bit
then we'll move on to your questions and
stuff after fayette
jumps in but the verses i want to
mention from the quran
allah says
he says indeed you will die and indeed
they will die or indeed they will die
and indeed you will die
um
and you'll both be raised basically back
to allah on the day of judgment
and to dispute in front of your lord
and who was worse than somebody who lies
about allah
and life and so on and so forth
and that jahannam hellfire has been
created for the disbelieving people
um so that is one of the most important
things in islam that we speak the truth
about god and only that which he reveals
about himself
that's very powerful man
yeah as i said for me that was the most
shocking part for muslims that's the
most obvious part but if you haven't
looked into the religion you don't
recognize that it is a religion
or i would say
if not the purest religion of monotheism
that's definitely not what i expected
looking into the quran so that was what
was leaving me flabbergasted after
reading it
you want me to put up the video
what's going on yeah we got a little bit
of a surprise for you we want to get a
pure you told me i'm excited what's
happening
before we play i just want to mention
that i selected this surah from the
quran based on your story actually thank
you very much one question did you just
read it did you read it or did you
recite it yourself
uh this surah yeah i i
initially i was trying to learn it so i
was listening to a reciter recited but
this was actually subhanallah this was
one of my favorite surahs like
two years back and i remembered it when
i heard your story i'm like man was that
surah and then i went and i found out
i'm like this is perfect nice yeah it's
fitting thank you very much let's put it
up there
let's go
absolutely beautiful
the last sentence that you don't will
anything that allah wills
is
a really striking home for me personally
that's what we briefly touched upon the
beginning when i said that you might
have your own will even when it comes
down to dietary practices or whatever it
might be
but ultimately you cannot go against the
will of god
if you don't submit to the will of god
you're always inconsistent suffering and
then to him you will be returned again
that was found in there as well that's
very beautiful man
powerful yeah that's funny every time i
listen to a man it's it's the same
feeling it doesn't get old it's just
like straight goosebumps and when you
listen to it you reflect on it it's so
powerful a lot so powerful in my
personal opinion but um
yes
bro
bro wallahi man i'm not just saying this
for the video but every time i listen to
the quran or i read the quran it just
hits me in the fields man even seeing
like the the video that we pulled up the
recitation just the verses it's almost
like you you read this like 100 times in
your life thousand times in life million
times but every time you read it it
gives you direct context and reflection
on what you've gone through in life it's
always relevant and i think that
transcends any other any other book in
the world a book that's man-made or a
book that just made you know just to
appeal to our desires bro this this
truly is the word of god bro and those
that believe otherwise i i highly
recommend you all to do exactly what
bobby did even if you don't go into it
with some type of intention go into it
with which is zero i guess bias because
that's a huge important thing and just
to see where it goes
yeah even though i have to say that even
going in with the bias like i did
because i went in with the bias to find
the devil that's cool too just do it
that way then i did it too and i didn't
find him so even with the bias still
just make yourself read the whole book
and then see how you feel after that
because when i discuss with people they
always tell me yeah i read some passages
okay where how couple of passages that
you found online i never see anybody
that really tells me i read the whole
quran from cover to cover and i came to
that in that conclusion nobody ever does
that yeah see see there's there's
christians today right i say christians
and they watch david woods videos bro
they watch apos they watch all these
youtubers that they really don't have
any idea what they're talking about
about islam and you mentioned a little
bit about that so tell us about your
relationship with just
any of these apologetics that are
actually islamophobes sure
ultimately it happened when i
again reverted or converted called what
you will to christian orthodoxy and i
wanted to stand firm within my faith
that's when i explored certain debates
christians with versus muslims etc etc
and then i found out about david wood
and he has a very interesting video
credit where credit is due it's a one
take video in black and white where he
tells his whole story about being an
atheist and then come into faith
it's really well done i have to say
because this guy is walking down the
subway station and is recording over his
shoulder talking to the camera
and it's one take from one station
through the subway and he comes out in
new york city and he tells this whole
story quite impressive really really
well done and he never grasps for words
or anything
it's
a magnificent video i still have to give
it to him but in that video he talks
about that he used to be a psychopath
and
took a hammer to smash his father's head
in
so it's a
testament to who this guy is ultimately
but that didn't make me shy away from
watching his content and his content i
mean obviously you guys are familiar
with it
for me just confirmed yet again my then
hatred towards islam and my suspicion
about islam so i just took it at face
value the guy just takes a surah or
takes a hadith and just talks about it
puts into a certain context tells you
that all the muslims are out there to
get you and they're all planning the
silent jihad
they're not your average neighbor
they're all conspiring against you
so ultimately i believed what he said
without ever reading the quran and it
was easy to simply google certain things
certain hadiths that he mentioned and
then oh yeah here it is i found it as
well myself now so therefore he must be
right
then later on i found the guy that you
call apus as well that guy was never too
convincing to me he seemed very
wishy-washy a bit all over the place
just wasn't a strong character david
wood at least is well spoken let's give
him that and therefore it was a better
presentation that was somewhat appealing
april's not so much he had this sneaky
atheistic vibe about him that i simply
dislike in general i don't really like
to listen to atheists because atheists
have no ground to stand on there is no
logic within anything they gonna tell
you they're gonna tell you that their
words are important but there is no
moral origin there is no universal
morals there is absolutely no
implication of right and wrong and no
implication of truth but hey listen to
me what i'm saying is true so why would
i listen to your words to begin with
it's completely ridiculous so therefore
atheists were never compelling to me to
begin with however from a christian
standpoint even though david wood is not
a christian orthodox
it was somewhat compelling and i felt
reaffirmed and simply strengthened
within my own belief system because if
you have an enemy
it's much easier to stand firm within
your ground as well i mean no matter how
you look at it let's be fair here even
as muslims then you have the rest the
liberal west for example even just
seeing that group of people that gives
you of course a reaffirmation of your
own faith so this is how i saw it ah
okay christianity true islam wrong islam
bad and therefore
he must be right
yeah
but ultimately
the muslims were right as well that
david woods
makes really good promotion for islam
because
he made me read the quran indirectly as
well right i got interested in islam
through his videos then i started
watching the debates with him and
mohammed hijab and other people
i was quite interesting to see and to
follow down that rabbit hole so i would
say that nevertheless even a bad
promotion is still promotion
so don't knock it it's still good for
islam
yeah you hear a lot um people who
mention that you know oh i looked into
islam after 9 11. i heard a lot about
muslims and they were this and they were
that and their terrorists and all all
these you know horrible things because
of 9 11 and other events
and then they look into islam and they
find you know
if if they incline towards peace also
inclined towards peace what is this
what is this religion you know i thought
it's supposed to be you know i'll kill
these people kill that people
you know this is a lot more peaceful
this talks about god this talks about
living life being good to your neighbors
giving to the orphans taking care of the
poor and all these beautiful things that
you know i thought only you know white
european people could practice
only they can do it huh it's only the
whites
we got our friday congregational prayers
soon um what we're gonna do is we're
gonna definitely have angel back you
back and we're gonna have like a proper
normal episode and definitely go deeper
but before we wrap it up i know you got
some few questions so i do want to hear
them out so miss mila bro take it away
okay man so we already have to wrap it
up i said it in the beginning i need at
least two hours man one hour is too
short for me i always like to ramble but
anyways i just wrote down some questions
that are concerning to me or of interest
to me after reading the quran of course
so the quran especially after we heard
that recitation you guys said as well
the quran is the word of god yeah in the
quran itself it is mentioned that the
quran is clear and therefore my
follow-up question is simply if it is
clear if it is the word of god
why do we need hadiths in order to
understand the quran this is something
that i'm trying to wrap my head around
yeah so allah with the quran when he
revealed it he revealed it in ver in
regards to very specific situations and
i will talk about what hadith are in a
second but he revealed the quran for
example a woman would come to the
prophet peace be upon him and ask
something like why does allah always
mention the guys or is the men you know
muslim which is the the masculine plural
it does encompass women as well
linguistically speaking but it could
also just specifically refer to men so
it's the process he didn't have the
answer he didn't know and then allah
revealed the verses
the muslim men and the muslim women the
believing man and the believing woman
and so on and so forth
in regards to that specifically so the
quran being clear
he says he revealed it in a clear arabic
meaning that when we read it in the
original language it is something that
is easily understood as we can go back
to the prophet which is when the hadith
comes in and see exactly how it was
understood by them
so we don't speak classical arabic today
naturally right if we did then the quran
would be a lot more clear if we
understood the words they were using so
the disconnect is mainly because of that
not just transition from one language to
arabic but from arabic to classic
classical arabic right think about
classical english and how different it
is to regular english how difficult it
is to read i would say it's somewhat
similar so the quran itself is clear but
to answer the question why do we have
hadith the quran itself says that we
have revealed the quran so that you can
explain it to them
because
the quran was sent in pair with what we
call the hikmah as the quran mentions or
the prophet mentioned
and the hikmah is the wisdom of the
prophet peace be upon him and the sunnah
that he followed so although the quran
is
generally clear which i'll explain it
like this the quran itself covers
everything vastly whether it's general
or specific but when we read the quran
we don't have all the knowledge to begin
with to understand exactly what it is
referring to in all the context so when
we refer to the sunnah of the prophet
peace be upon him which
look at the example the prophet we find
a lot more of a clear example because we
have him as the example so i hope that
makes sense it's mainly
a um
a translational issue and also the way
they spoke with the classical arabic
back then is very different to us but if
we spoke it we would understand it a lot
clearer
that makes sense
that makes sense because there was
something that became interesting to me
after reading the quran and i heard of
groups that call themselves quranists
that was their argumentation as well
yeah and then of course you have the
sunni muslims that would be totally
against that
and yeah there was something that was on
my mind the clarification so if it is a
translational issue that would make even
more sense yeah interesting thank you of
course of course
all right next question
next question is
what i found interesting is when i was
reading the quran it mentioned the
people of the book
the christians it mentioned the jews
and it didn't necessarily at least the
way that i understood it is why i'm
asking
didn't necessarily mention conversion of
those people however it spoke about the
context of clarification
and i was wondering
is the quran appealing
to the christians and to the jews to
return to monotheism within their
traditions or is it to leave them
completely behind and everybody converts
to islam
so
it's for everyone to accept islam and
that's shown in two ways allah says in
the quran that there is no deen no way
or system of life that's accepted except
islam
and that whoever so turned away from
islam you know after it being presented
to them they are a catholic they are a
disbeliever and they will be punished
for their basically neglecting of that
because when allah
sends you know jesus
to the people and you have christians
following him and then later you know as
we believe the message gets corrupted
that's no longer the religion of god so
and then allah he sends the same message
with a different prophet a new messenger
that original message is what you are
supposed to follow so if you have
something that's maybe let's say 98
truthful but two percent corrupted
versus something that's 100 truthful
where
you know by definition of what the truth
is you should go for 100
uh to get the full message and the other
example i can give is the prophets upon
giving dawah to jews and christians to
come and accept islam and jews and
christians accepting islam and actually
a main one of the main things that the
quran refers to is the book
you know the bible the old testament and
what the christians had at the time as
well because they had mention of a
prophet that's coming to them and the
jews actually used to say to the arabs
at the time you know just wait for our
prophet to come he's going to come here
he's going to come soon just wait we're
going to basically win and beat you guys
later on and when the autumn's heard
that and this man named muhammad peace
be upon him came claiming to be a
prophet and he kind of fit the criteria
they're like we should get on this now
because this is what the jews are always
threatening us with you know their
prophet stuff but 100 is clear with the
quran and the sunnah that the prophet
peace upon them called them to come
practice islam
very very interesting man that brings me
to the next one
and it is essentially the last one
asking questions about the quran in
itself
you mentioned
bringing people back to the true
religion and the way that i understood
it again because i just read the quran
now i started reading certain hadiths i
started with sahih bukhari and the way
that i understood islam
essentially we're talking about the
submission to god so therefore we have a
line of prophets you have abraham who
was the first that really submitted to
god
in terms of prophets here on earth
before that you had adam that is
considered a prophet as well because he
was in direct submission to god
my question is is that submission to god
directly linked
to islam to let's say the organized
religion of islam the way that we see it
nowadays
or is there a way to submit to god
let's say
for the lack of better words in a
different fashion because i have to
question if abraham and jesus and moses
if they all submitted in the same way
that we see muslims submit nowadays does
that make sense yeah yeah so butcher a
little bit no no no i got the question i
got honesty i understand what you're
asking and it's i think it's a common
question for a lot of people
um how did these prophets practice what
did it look like
are we similar there's actually a very
interesting debate between adnan rasheed
and james white
where they talk about who resembles
jesus more specifically
christians or muslims
and uh you'll find that not only do
muslims resemble jesus more based on the
bible itself
but we actually resemble abraham more
noah moore david moore all the prophets
mentioned the bible more because they
were people who you know perhaps fasted
who uh prayed and prostrated with their
head on the ground exactly like muslims
jesus you know you described him before
relating to the other muslim brother as
with the long beard and long hair which
is the son of the prophet peace be upon
him as well
so in terms of submitting to god and
what does that look like as a muslim
when we say
we're not just saying that oh there's no
god except allah what we're truly saying
is that there is no one who i take away
of life from no one who i take morality
from knowing that i you know learn about
how i should live and what's good and
what's bad and all of these things
except god i don't let people tell me
how life should be what the purpose of
life is and or anything really for that
matter except god
and because of that anything that god
tells me to do i will do and anything
god tells me not to do i will not do and
anything that is preferred i will strive
to do in anything that is disliked i
will you know try and shy away from and
that's basically what being a muslim
means muslim
basically muslim is someone who
practices practices islam and islam
comes from the term salam which means
submission so when we say submission
it's what you mentioned before
submission to the will of god so even if
you know how abraham lived looked a
little bit different to how i lived it
could just be because god commanded him
to live in one way and god commanded us
to live in another but regardless there
is no real difference allah he mentions
the quran that abraham peace be upon him
was not a jew nor was he a christian but
he was an upright man and that he was
someone who was named who who was given
the title of khalillah the friend of
allah because of
uh as allah mentioned this in surah
najam he's someone who fulfills his
obligations perfectly and that's the
definition of someone who submits to
allah someone who fulfilled the
obligations in regards to god
yeah exactly that's exactly what i was
wondering about because islam itself
this submission of your will
must be something so universal that
could be then found even outside of the
now islamic context so i'm a
universalist in a sense if you will i
would have to believe that
if i would be on a lonely island with no
input from anybody there must be a way
how i would submit to god even without
learning anything from any other man
yeah directly from god there must be
this innate predisposition where i just
understand
which relation i stand to my creator
yeah
yeah i wanted to really quickly jump in
and say that islam we understand it's
it's both a revealed religion and a
natural religion so just like
was saying just like you were saying yes
the new islam the islam from 1400 years
ago although we believe that islam was
there since the beginning of time when
allah sent you know prophet adam the
first man on earth um adam was a muslim
peace be upon him you know so all
messengers and prophets were muslim but
it's also unnatural religion we have the
fitra which is the innate predisposition
that you mentioned and we all have the
world born with that everyone's born
with that it's just society parents
circumstances that change it
right on
okay guys we are already at it for one
hour 11. i asked my questions pretty
much all of them i don't want to drag it
on for too long
i don't want to hold you up
run me bro you're going to say something
you muted microsoft my buddy i turned it
off instead of on my bad i was going to
mention the fitzroy but you basically
covered it someone asked the stream
ended so i got worried and just checked
but i think we're good in sha allah but
yeah the fitzra is something the natural
you know predisposition that you spoke
about uh whereas uh basically it's it's
what you saw in yourself as a kid when
you're connected to god it's what you
see in kids all around and the study
that was done i think at oxford
university where they basically
conducted a study and found that
every single kid
believes in a higher power believes in
god one god from a young age and that's
what we would call the fitra that it's
the same thing atheists
experience when they're about to you
know die or they're in a tragic
situation they call it to god regardless
that's just the natural disposition that
we have as humans
make sense
yeah
yeah bobby you got no more questions
i had a few more but i just didn't want
to go on for too long
should i ask you how much time we got i
got about nine minutes yeah uh about
about nine minutes yeah we can fit okay
then continue bro
i have a question about jesus then
do you think that jesus
aside from him submitting to god i think
that is universal within the prophets as
well i would agree with that
do you think that he had any other
mission as well was his mission
different
than any other prophets do all the
prophets differ within their missions
so
the prophets don't differ in their
missions actually there's a verse in the
quran or allah he says specifically that
the believers they say certain things
they say you know
that i believe in allah and his angels
and his books and his messengers
and then we say that we don't make any
differentiation between the messengers i
as a believer i don't differentiate
between them and that
in some in one case allah he refers to
people as disbelieving in the the
messengers plural
because if you reject one you basically
reject them all because they came with
the same exact message the only
difference with isa alaihissalam is also
the messiah and the messiah i know
christianity is something that they see
as oh he has to die for our sins and
that's what the anointed person does
because messiah means anointed
we believe that the anointed
messiah is supposed to come back in the
end of times and be with the muslims and
kill the antichrist and be a sign for
the worlds as allah describes him in the
quran
we see it the same way that jesus will
return and fight the antichrist that is
the same in the eschatology of christian
orthodoxy too
with of course the difference of the
dying for your sins part
but other than that jesus preached that
the kingdom of heaven is within would
you say that that is relating to the
fitra or how would you interpret that
that's very interesting it's very
interesting i think um i think in that
context you could say that you could say
that it's
but on the kingdom of god specifically i
find you find something very interesting
and and i think the second daniels
with the the dream that the babylonian
king had so basically long story short
he saw a dream where he saw a statue
with a gold head silver torso uh bronze
legs and then the feet were iron mixed
with clay and then we saw a big boulder
fall down from the sky crush the statue
and then cement itself to the ground and
become a mountain
and david uh he interpreted was no not
david um
daniel pardon me daniel interpreted this
dream for the king
and he said that your kingdom is the
head of the statue
and then your kingdom will be overcome
by another and that will be overcome by
another and that will be overcome by
another and then you'll have the kingdom
of god
destroy basically or conquer all
kingdoms that were left and
basically be the firm kingdom of god on
earth
now if you look at the history this was
babylon right who conquered the
who conquered the babylonians the
mesopotamians
who conquered the mesopotamians the
persians who conquered the persians the
romans who conquered the romans and
anything remaining from any other
kingdom it was the muslims
and then they ruled for 1400 years under
their sharia under their islamic law
which we see as being the kingdom of god
man that's deep yeah yeah something to
look into actually i saw one video about
a christian who was interpreting it and
he said himself if you interpret this in
a literal way you come to find that the
muslims are the kingdom of god which is
problematic so it must not be literally
it must not be true then
yeah
after all yeah i did all the research
but it's wrong yeah this video don't
watch it guys
exactly that man
let's uh i think we have time for maybe
one or two more
one
more question i had a question about
circumcision
yeah
how does it look like for reverts do
they have to get circumcised that's a
good question i don't know i don't know
as a matter that's a matter of the
rulings in islam and i'm not well versed
on that so i personally don't know
would you know if i have
would i no i wouldn't know bro
yeah there was something of interest to
me
i know that jesus even according to the
bible was circumcised don't get me wrong
there yeah
yeah yeah so what i'm going to do
there's a website called islam
it's a very trusted website so i'm just
going to quickly look at it even though
i'm going to still tell you know consult
a scholar but in the meantime you could
ask me if you have any other alternative
question
honestly this is pretty much all i wrote
down for now i have to do my own
research further
i through this journey realized that
we can literally hold
absolute opposite
opinions in two different time frames
the bobby just a year ago hated islam
with the vengeance and now i find it's
to be quite the beautiful philosophy so
that is
a totally different stance and therefore
i don't want to ask too much i want to
do my own digging then further and learn
more if i have something on the way of
course i will always reach out to
muslims i have many of muslim followers
nowadays especially
but as for right now that's all with
questioning man
all right all right my man i appreciate
it very much they're really really
common questions i think and i'm glad
that you're asking them as you go along
for sure
thank you very much for having me guys
welcome anytime you're welcome anytime
bro it was a pleasure speaking with you
and chopping it up uh anyone that made
it this far or just joined in the stream
and they didn't pick up anything else
just
you can bro if there's one thing you
take away
but aside from that anyone interested in
the quran definitely hit us up um
there's a few good transitions inshallah
that we can put in the description
we look forward to seeing you next time
[Music]
thank you very much again for having me
guys all the best
do i say ramadan
i'm not too sure yeah
have fun breaking your fast later on
enjoy the dates
oh yeah i will for sure man every single
night break it with the date that's the
son of the prophet peace be upon him and
with that being said
[Music]
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi